yeah what have you learned about men
from doing this they're dogs
a lot of men cheat on their wives
a lot it's crazy
all right all right rosie hi
rosie uh where'd you grow up where are
you from originally i'm from sacramento
california
sacramento and uh tell me about your
childhood you had both your parents when
you were young
um no i had my dad and his mom
uh my my mom was absent she was out of
the picture but i grew up with my dad
where was your mom i don't know out
running the streets probably
and how did you describe your childhood
it was decent
it was fair until i was 10 years old
when my grandma passed away
and then i went to [ __ ] from there what
kind of stuff went on
um i ended up in the foster system um
i was pregnant and became awarded court
and pregnant at the same time pregnant
at what age
14 14. so you have children today
yes i do how many kids six six kids yes
did you raise uh no your kids my two
youngest ones i raised them until
recently
and then i had to give them to the
grandma because life got hard
yeah and how far did you go in school
ninth grade ninth grade yeah and you
started doing this kind of work at what
age
uh three months ago four months ago oh
just recently
yes that's interesting yeah so how did
this happen you just got
um money's tight yeah well i talked to a
friend of mine
and i asked him about like stripping and
then
we got into the escorting stuff and
that's how it happened
wow so so you're new to this how has it
been so far
yes and no it's been up and down a
little bit up and down i've had
good days i've had bad days and
being in reno i had way more bad days
than good days oh doing this in reno's
yeah sucks so what was it like in reno
for you
horrible in what ways it was horrible um
i met a lot of fake people i met some
real people
um i went through
something traumatic just two weeks ago
but
and all in all i'm okay what kind of
stuff have you encountered on the street
um i hear a lot of stories so nothing to
surprise me
um a lot of things that i've encountered
on the streets
like like have you had problems with
tricks
uh what have you had problems with some
of the tricks that have picked you up uh
yes and no no not really
no i mean they didn't want to pay me is
pay me the money that we agreed upon
or they would want to take me in this
big old goose chase
over some money and i'm just like okay
whatever
but nothing really is too serious it was
more so the people that i was
um in a circle of like friends you can
call it
that did me more dirtier than
my actual tricks did so and what it
would
what's been your experience since you're
new at this
you know what what are the ups and downs
of this lifestyle the money's fast right
yeah the money's fast but me being a new
person and a newcomer
in this situ in this industry it's like
kind of harder for them to
think of me as somebody that's not a
catfish
because i've been told that i my profile
looks fake
oh is that right yeah
and you're working without a pen yes
is that problematic no no you're doing
this on figaro street
or um i haven't really done it out here
in la yet i had just
been in la for like seven days okay so i
just got out here yeah
so sacramento you do it on the street or
i've done it on stockton boulevard i've
done it in oakland
but i i mostly post ads yeah so
and are drugs part of your life drugs
are history they're part of my history
yes
yeah which drugs have you played around
with um
heroin cocaine meth
ecstasy pretty much all of them shrooms
pretty much all of them yeah
so in the uh
the lack of support in your family do
you feel like that was a factor in
where you're no i think it was more so
the factor with my family it was i
pushed myself away from them
because i i just couldn't bring myself
to come around my family when i was
under the influence
so so you're using drugs at an early age
i started
at 18. but you went to the foster system
earlier
didn't you yeah i was in the foster
system earlier i was only smoking weed
then
i wasn't introduced to hardcore drugs
because i wasn't out there
like hardcore hardcore
until i was 18. so how has this
new new career for you affected you you
get depressed about doing it sometimes
no not really when i go into it or like
when i go to meet a client or something
that
i go into it and i shut off my emotions
or the feelings that i would have like
the pleasure feelings that you would get
out of anything like that i i shut it
off
it's just business yeah it's just
business i just got to get the money and
get out you know
yeah what have you learned about men
from doing this
they're dogs a lot of men cheat on their
wives
a lot it's crazy
and does it does this build your
self-esteem doing this work or does it
undermine it
um it doesn't really undermine my
self-esteem it doesn't even boost it
either i mean i'm
i think it's more so i have a lot of
confidence in myself that's great
so like even if i didn't have this if it
wasn't a long-term career or long-term
something that i was looking for
long-term it wouldn't bother me to get
out
i wouldn't feel less of myself or more
of myself
i think i more so feel less of myself
because i should have been making a lot
of money by now
are you doing this because of like covid
and job layoffs and things like that
yeah so it's just you find yourself in a
corner in a jam and you needed to do
something to make money
pretty much did the shame play a part in
your life now that you're doing this
kind of work
the shame i mean it's more shameful
no not really no i can't really say that
that's honest
i don't feel shame in it it's like i'm
very careful and i'm very
um safe so
i mean if i was out there selling my
body for like 40 bucks
a pop then yeah i probably feel shameful
but i don't
do it to get high i don't do it to
support my drug habit i do it to
keep money in my pocket survive
what mistakes have you made that you've
learned from um
in life or or just in this line of work
in this line of work um
um make sure i get some money first
yeah make sure it's a for sure thing
because sometimes like i'll go out for
an out call or something and
they'll send me to this bogus ass
address you know
are they doing it online yeah posting
ads yeah
because i'm really i'm not too too much
of a street walker
i like to post my ads in
and chill inside because i get a little
bit
of anxiety when i have too much
attention on me
so have you been loved before
huh have you been in love before oh yeah
i have
you've had good relationships yeah for
the most part that's great
what was the best time of your life the
best time of my life was
um in 2017
when i had my son i mean i've had six
best times in my life but i had my son
and i got my daughter back from cps and
i
married the love of my life but he's not
here now
he's in prison
and you what are your plans to walk away
from this my plans is to yeah
walk away from it sooner than i expect
i haven't hit the big money yet you know
so i don't think that's why
i think that's why it's like not
weighing down on me
and i think that's why it's probably
easier for me to walk away from it now
than it would have been if i was hitting
money on top of money is that why you
came to l.a
to make more money no i came to la to
get away from
reno
i understood or two people from reno so
yeah i had to
i was supposed to be in arkansas but it
started raining or snowing so
they closed the roads down and i had a
delay for my bus
and still delayed so i'm in
l.a and who's raising your kids right
now their grandma
your grandmother yes
what advice would you give to somebody
who's short on money and thinking about
this as a career
go in it with somebody who knows what
they're talking about
and if you're a girl don't do it with a
pimp
so how do you do it with somebody who
knows what they're talking about but
isn't a pimp
well for the most part i got all my
lessons or all my tips from a female
oh is that right yes
i just i i would sit back and i would
watch how she would do her stuff
and or or i would sit back and watch how
other girls did theirs and then i would
take
notes you know are the girls helpful to
each other in terms of like showing
a newbie the ropes no yeah for the most
part
yeah some some of my friends were kind
of standoffish because i wasn't it
wasn't something that anybody would ever
see me doing
but when i started it they were kind of
shocked and they were like rosie are you
sure you want to do this and i was like
uh
yeah i don't want to be broke
so for the most part yeah was it
difficult the first time for you
um the first time no because i did when
i first started out
doing this stuff in this line of
business i did have a pimp
well you did but he was the only pimp
i've ever had
and the only pimp i will ever have what
was it what was the
problem with that relationship uh i got
a smart ass mouth and i don't listen
and pimps don't play so
and on top of it i had to live up to my
nickname which was renegade rosie
hmm so now you're a renegade now i'm a
renegade
[Music]
what's the most important lesson you've
learned in your life um the most
important lesson
that i've learned in life is to not
trust everybody
because i'm the kind of person that
trusts everybody
but in this line of work it's got to be
tough to trust anyone because
oh in this line of work it's it's kind
of tough to figure out who your real
friends are because
if you have real friends they really
wouldn't care if you had money or not
but the the snakes and the fakes
they're only there for the money and the
drugs and whatever they can get from you
so as long as you keep handing them
out they're going to keep their hands
out
what was the worst time of your life the
worst time of my life was two weeks ago
what happened um i got tied up and
tortured for four hours
some ex-boyfriend of mine well he was
supposed to be my boyfriend
that's why you ran away from that's why
i left reno
you believe in karma oh yeah i believe
in karma
how does karma play a role in your life
uh she did play a big role because i
i used to be um i used to get nervous
about
like doing these clients that i would
just get the money and not do anything
and take off you know
and sometimes it's kind of bad and i've
done things in my life that ain't too
good but i do believe that what i dealt
with last
two weeks ago was my bad karma it was
your payback
i feel like that was my payback and from
here on out i ain't even gonna mess with
karma because that [ __ ] is real
you have to worry about police getting
arrested stuff like that no
no it's easier when you're doing it
online right
yeah pretty much because it's like when
you ask
a question are you are you affiliated
with law enforcement or are you a pimp
and they have to answer ah they have to
advertise
you ask that just to make sure it's not
a cop yes and then then
because if they tell you no and they
really are a cop then it goes against
all the rules
do you feel like something in your
childhood if it was different may have
may have changed the direction of your
life
me a lot like mom being your picture mom
being there
um not having to be in cps
a lot of things
but i wouldn't change my past for
anything because
in my future it's going to be something
that's going to help save somebody
else's life
a lot of people call me a warrior but
i'm just human
you're strong and you're hopeful very
much so that's great
yes those are great qualities to have
i still smile i still see good in the
world when there's evil out there
so that's great all right rosie thank
you so much for talking with me
thank you and i wish you the best of
luck out there be careful thanks
thank you